chuck schumer dances as americans are
stuck in kabul the biden administration
has no good answers to just why joe
biden is disconnected from reality and
isis is on the rise again i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment there's a lot of it none of
it is good we'll get to that in just one
second first take a look at your cell
phone bill if you're with verizon or at
t or t-mobile you're paying too much
it's time to switch over to puretalk
puretalk can save your family over 800 a
year it's a lot of money you've got the
same great coverage because pure talk is
on the exact same network as one of the
big three but at a fraction of the price
and switching is super easy all you have
to do is switch out your sim card you
can keep your phone keep your number or
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids plus right now you get a
limited talk text and six gigs of data
for just 30 bucks a month and if you go
over on the data they're not going to
charge you for it there's a reason pure
talk is the highest rated wireless
company by consumer affairs and why they
are the preferred wireless partner of
amac right now you should switch over
your coverage because you could be
saving yourself a lot of money plus
if from your cell phone you do this you
dial pound 250 and say my name ben
shapiro you will save an additional 50
off your very first month you're already
saving a lot of money and 50 off your
first month when you go to pound 250 on
your phone and say ben shapiro to get
started with my friends over at pure
talk usa save yourself hundreds of
dollars a year pure talk usa dial pound
two five zero say my name ben shapiro to
get started alrighty so
apparently the leadership of the
democratic party they just don't care
very much i'm not sure how else to read
their activities this weekend
you had nancy pelosi off in napa valley
dining with the dccc and you had chuck
schumer dancing it up with stephen
colbert in new york city this is kind of
an astonishing tape given the fact that
there are currently thousands of
american citizens stuck in kabul and the
senate majority leader is dancing it up
with stephen colbert according to the
new york post
senate senator chuck schumer was ripped
on twitter for dancing with stephen
colbert backstage at the we love nyc
concert amid the ongoing catastrophe in
afghanistan and as the coronavirus
pandemic continues to surge across the
u.s backstage antics wrote mayor de
blasio's press secretary bill nye heart
in a twitter posting on saturday before
the star-studded concert in central park
was abruptly canceled because of storms
and lightning generated by hurricane
hari so it's uh yeah god was like no and
uh and thus was the we love nyc
celebration cancelled here was a little
bit of some incredibly awkward dancing
between the senate majority leader and a
man who used to be funny at one point
stephen colbert although it's been a
long time it's hard to remember i know
[Music]
here comes stephen colbert
it's just a disaster area not just the
dancing not just the dancing
backstage between stephen colbert
whose job it is to target politicians
and uh and chuck schumer the senate
majority leader it's just it's wonderful
wonderful stuff happening meanwhile
thousands of americans are still stuck
in kabul with no way out and now
the taliban are openly mocking us so
they put up a photo
of their guys raising a taliban flag in
the same exact formation as the marines
on iwo jima in world war ii
according to the marine corps times in
one particular image released this week
members of the taliban badri 313
battalion appeared to mock joe
rosenthal's iconic 1945 image of the
flag raised atop mount suribachi during
the battle of iwo jima and the taliban
image fighters belonging to badri 313
which some are calling the taliban's
elite commando unit are shown wearing
full camouflage uniforms combat boots
tactical gear and night vision goggles
similar photographs released in recent
days show taliban fighters carrying
weapons and equipment issued by the
united states or allied nations
including m4 carbines and what appear to
be trijicon advanced combat optical gun
sights or acogs
the images are noticeable departure from
traditional depictions of taliban
fighters who seldom appeared with heavy
weaponry or in full military garb spoils
left behind by the afghan army so things
are going really well they're going even
better than that actually it turns out
that over at the airport
a fox news reporter is suggesting lucas
tomlinson that the taliban have been
stepping up attacks on afghans outside
abigail kabul airport they have been
tearing up passports and other vital
documents one afghan trying to escape
says the taliban knocked his wife's
teeth out at a checkpoint which of
course is no shock at all
you have to understand
that the kabul airport you think of an
airport as like a big place with a lot
of runways kabul airport is not a big
place with a lot of runways kabul
airport is a postage stamp bagram
airport which we
ridiculously surrendered to the taliban
for no apparent reason was a very large
airport kabul is one runway
literally one all the taliban have to do
to knock out the ability of anyone to
fly anything out of afghanistan at this
point is send one mortar around into the
runway that's it
and everybody knows this which is why
they are treating the taliban with kid
gloves meanwhile the taliban are
basically screening whoever goes through
the checkpoint the security and this has
resulted not just in afghans being
targeted but also in americans being
targeted as well lloyd austin the
secretary of defense he admitted over
the weekend that americans are basically
being beaten by the taliban as they
approach these checkpoints
if you have
an american passport and if you have the
right credentials the taliban has been
allowing people to uh to pass safely
through not in all cases
there's no such thing as an absolute in
this kind of environment as you would
imagine uh martha there there have been
incidents of
uh people uh you know having some some
tough encounters with with taliban as we
learn about those uh incidents we
certainly go back and engage the taliban
leadership and and uh and press home to
them that our expectation is that they
allow uh you know our people with the
with the appropriate credentials to get
through the
through the checkpoints oh well you know
as long as we're as long as we're
conveying our feelings to the taliban
obviously that will change things by the
way the state department guidance right
now is utterly unclear they're basically
saying we can't guarantee your safety to
get to the airport you should wait until
we get back to you and give you
instructions but also don't call us
because we're overwhelmed
so it remains a complete crap show over
in kabul
meanwhile tony blinken is trying to
explain that the best way to get to the
kabul airport is to go yourself we're
not going to be sending soldiers out
there the way that the british have with
the italians have like there are other
people who are out there what the
ukrainians have like they're sending
their military into the city to go pick
up their citizens and bring them back
but apparently not the united states
tony blinken is saying basically you
have to get there yourself and we'll try
to figure out a way to get you out but
we can't guarantee your safety getting
there but also we're not gonna come get
you so imagine for a second that you
were now you were an american stuck in
afghanistan what would you do at this
point would you try to brave the
thousands of people who are now
surrounding the kabul airport including
taliban fighters to get through there
let's say you're an american woman and
you're trying to get through how would
this go for you do you feel perfectly
comfortable that you would get through
the phalanx of taliban fighters and
barbarians who are now guarding the
airport tony blinken says well you know
we're doing our best
the best way the most effective way the
way i'm focused on to get folks in again
is to be in direct contact with them uh
and to help guide them in to give them
instructions on where to go uh when to
go there
and then we can we can bring them into
the airport safely and effectively so
they are still effectively on their own
getting to the airport
uh
again uh we found that the the best way
to do this is to be in direct touch with
them um president secretary defense have
been clear that uh we will uh do
whatever it takes to get americans uh
home and and out of harm's way oh you'll
be in touch with them you see you'll
talk them through it hmm
yes i'm sure that as people hear stories
about people having the crap beat out of
them by the taliban their first thought
is well probably i'm just going to go
there you know i mean like what's what
could be the harm exactly meanwhile jake
sullivan the national security adviser
he admits there's still several thousand
americans trying to get out of kabul now
remember none of this counts presumably
the hundreds or thousands of americans
were not in kabul right this is just the
americans who are in kabul but they're
americans that ngos all over afghanistan
a lot of those people ain't coming home
a lot of and i promise you a year from
now there can be videos of americans in
afghanistan or being held hostage by the
taliban
if you think that american involvement
in afghanistan ended with joe biden
declaring that american involvement in
afghanistan is over
just watch the news for the next year or
so here's jake sullivan
exactly how many americans are left
behind in afghanistan
well nora the u.s government doesn't
actually know the precise answer to that
question and that's because we ask every
american who comes to afghanistan to
register with the u.s embassy but when
people leave they often don't deregister
and even some who come never register in
the first place well the clock is
ticking the deadline is approaching it's
just 12 days away you think you can have
all that buttoned up by then
we can move thousands of people every
single day between now and the end of
the month we have plenty more seats on
flights than we believe that there are
possibly americans still in afghanistan
yeah yeah so they have no idea how many
people are actually there
meanwhile fox news is trey yingst he
says there is no clear plan in place to
rescue the americans or outside of kabul
because remember again not all of the
americans are in kabul
the question we keep hearing whether
it's people reaching out online saying
we have relatives or friends trapped in
kabul or elsewhere they keep asking
what's the plan have you heard anything
who can i contact to make sure that my
loved ones get to the airport
and
while there is a limited plan to get
countries including the united states on
the ground here to evacuate those who
can make it to the airport there is no
clear plan in place
to save the thousands of americans who
are not only spread out around kabul but
in other cities
kandahar smaller cities around the
country
and they have no way to get here all of
this because joe biden decided to
precipitously pull out with no warning
right with that without really any plan
he said we were going to pull out april
14th but he didn't start actually
evacuating people so instead we just
moved the military out and we left all
the materiel and human beings behind
which is precisely the opposite of what
you would do even if you're in favor of
the withdrawal which again i think is is
politically foolish i think it's
geostrategically idiotic but even if
you're in favor of the withdrawal even
if you think that this is something that
had to be done we may as well do it
sooner rather than later you at least
have to leave the soldiers in there long
enough to make sure that we get our
stuff and people out instead we just
handed our military technology over to
the taliban we abandoned our air bases
we completely had we basically cut our
own hamstrings so we can't actually
effectuate
a way of getting people out of there
to the point where now
we not only do we not have an ability to
get people out of there the biden
administration is openly at this point
talking about bombing all of the people
and and resources that we left there so
the idea is we left all of these
military resources behind maybe we
should bomb them maybe we should just
blow up all the military resources
according to axios the administration is
considering launching airstrikes against
the larger equipment they fear that such
a move could provoke the taliban at a
time when the us is focusing on
evacuating people from afghanistan again
this is because we left these people in
charge these barbarians are in charge we
are no longer in charge over there
according to politico in the chaos of
the moment it's unclear to us officials
how much equipment the taliban has
seized and how much of that sits
unattended on bases and in small combat
outposts across the country that
uncertainty over the status of a massive
arsenal is sparking fears of a regional
arms bazaar that could be a boon to
terrorist groups and insurgents
the images that have spread across the
world over the past week of taliban
fighters posing in front of captured
helicopters and light attack aircraft
light attack aircraft have allowed the
group to further humiliate the former
afghan and american governments but
these images don't concern long-time
extremism watchers as much as the
proliferation of guns at bullets and
grenades
so now i guess we're going to have to
send troops back in to blow all that
stuff up so this has been just wonderful
cnn meanwhile reporting there really is
no access to the airport
the americans have closed all the gates
access there is no access to
the airport at the at the moment except
through one
british access point called camp baron
which is on the outskirts of the airport
where people are processed there and
then uh moved into the airport once
they've been cleared to fly out now that
has been the case now for many hours
that is sam kelly of cnn reporting as of
yesterday sky news also reporting on the
chaos and saying yeah no things are not
organized out here
this is an emergency now
it's nothing to do with process they're
just trying to save lives
sit down
tens of thousands are trying to get
through at the front they're being
crushed
paratroopers pulling people from the
mayhem
medics rushing from the next casualty to
the next
and the next the soldiers spray the
crowd with a hose anything to cool them
down
men women and lots and lots of children
please
[Music]
and then what we feared the inevitable
is this a stabilized withdrawal from
afghanistan
it looks like death to me
okay so that is a report from sky news
things going great though according to
the biden administration by the way
there have been at least 20 deaths in
the last week during the kabul airport
evacuation effort according to nato
that's how well things are going over
there including by the way a child like
at least a couple of children
seven people were crushed just over the
weekend in panic at the airport so
things are going absolutely swimmingly
thousands continue to try to flee the
country the british military on sunday
acknowledged at least seven deaths at
the airport
and again apparently one of the people
who was killed was a two-year-old
apparently soldiers had covered several
corpses in white clothing other troops
stood on concrete barriers trying to
calm down the crowd
others may have been trampled suffocated
or suffered heart attacks as taliban
fighters fired into the air to try to
drive back the crowds as
well and um apparently the uh the
temperatures have reached about 93
degrees fahrenheit over there so uh so
things are very hot and uh and sticky
and just it it's pretty terrible all the
way through
meanwhile who's actually setting the
rules here it's pretty obvious the
taliban are setting the rules we'll get
to that in just one second first let us
talk about your sleep quality so here's
the reality i've been recommending the
helixlee mattress to you for quite a
while but you don't just sleep on your
bed right you got to take a nap you lay
on your couch don't you well what if you
had a couch that was just as excellent
as your helix sleep mattress this is
what helix was thinking when they
launched a new company called all form
they are making premium customizable
sofas and chairs shipped directly to
your door we have an all form sofa it is
indeed spectacular the three-seat sofa
with chase and the sand color with
espresso legs it is so comfortable it is
definitely the preferred place for naps
in the shapiro household what makes an
all-form sofa really great well for
starters it's the easiest way you can
customize the sofa using premium
materials and at a fraction of the cost
of traditional stores you can pick your
fabric it is spill stainless scratch
resistant which is super useful when you
have kids the sofa color color of the
legs sofa size shape make sure it is
perfect for you and your home they've
got arm chairs and love seats all the
way up to an eight seat sectional so
there is something for everyone and you
can always start small and you can buy
more seats later on if you want your
all-form sofa to grow and change with
you when you move or when your family
grows all form sofas or delivered
directly to your door in the past if you
wanted to order a sofa you need to hire
somebody to come assemble it for you but
not anymore all form makes it quick and
easy they have a simple quick assembly
with no tools necessary and if getting a
sofa without trying it in store sounds
risky don't worry because you have 100
days to decide if you want to keep it
more than three months if you don't love
it they'll pick it up for free give you
a full refund and they have a forever
warranty literally for all time so to
find your perfect sofa check out form
dot com slash ben
that is all form.com and all form is
offering 20 off all orders for our
listeners at
allform.com get a great deal on a great
sofa allform.com
ben so the taliban are in charge at this
point and that is perfectly obvious so
joe biden said yesterday that maybe
we'll extend the august 31st deadline
remember there was this august 31st
deadline that he kept talking about over
and over and over right we we're going
to get out by august 31st then he says
well are you going to stay longer if
there's still americans on the ground
and he was like we'll do our best to get
out before august 31st and then george
stephanopoulos asked him last week but
you will extend the deadline and biden
said yeah maybe we'll extend the
deadline so yesterday joe biden said
maybe we'll extend the deadline
the august again deadline will you
extend that deadline or what what is
your thought process on
extending the evacuation operation
there's discussions going on among us
and the military about extending
our hope is we will not have to extend
but there are going to be discussions i
suspect on how far along we are in the
process okay so there are discussions on
whether we're going to have to extend in
the meantime in the meantime yeah the
taliban are saying you're not extending
they're like you know what we're not
going to let people through and you know
what this is this is a hostage situation
now
as i mentioned there's only one way out
of this hostage situation for the biden
administration that is to hand billions
of dollars to the taliban right we are
going to become the chief funders of
some of the worst terrorist supporters
on planet earth and the worst regime on
planet earth
that is what the united states has been
transformed to in from the greatest
fighting force on planet earth killing
tens of thousands of taliban members
every year in coordination with our
afghan allies to the people sponsoring
the taliban that is what we are going to
turn into because the taliban has now
met with sky news in doha qatar and here
is what sky news is reporting
taliban spokesperson dr suhel shaheen
said quote it's a red line president
biden announced on august 31st they
would withdraw all their military forces
so if they extend it that means they're
extending occupation there's no need for
that
if the us or uk were to seek additional
time to continue evacuations the answer
is no or there would be consequences it
will create mistrust between us if they
are intent on continuing the occupation
it will provoke a reaction
all of that comes as boris johnson is
personally begging with joe biden to
extend the deadline to allow more people
to flee the reign of terror of the
taliban meanwhile desperate scenes grow
at kabul international airport according
to sky news people prepared to leave
everything and risk their lives to
escape life under the militants group
rule when pressed on this issue that
people are clinging on to aircraft
leaving the country and that that is far
from routine dr shaheen he's probably
he's probably a great doctor probably dr
shaheen the spokesperson for the uh for
the taliban probably an excellent doctor
he said i assure you it is not about
being worried or scared
they want to reside in western countries
and that is kind of economic migration
because afghanistan is poor and 70 of
the people in afghanistan live under the
poverty line so everyone wants to
resettle in western countries to have a
prosperous life but it's not about being
scared of the taliban
when asked about footage that the
taliban are going door to door and
threatening people and closing down
girls schools and banning women from
television
and when asked about a story from cnn
that the brother of an afghan translator
was uh just murdered the other day and
cnn is reporting that the taliban have
sentenced the brother of an afghan
translator to death according to letters
obtained by cnn accusing him of helping
the us and providing security to his
brother who served as an interpreter to
american troops
so the taliban are obviously doing all
this sort of stuff dr sheen said all
fake news i can assure you there are
many reports by our opponents claiming
what is not based in reality
dr shaheen said the women who stay in
the country will lose nothing only if
they have no hijab they will have a
hijab women are required to have the
same rights as you have in your country
oh the hijab
when pressed on this issue shaheen said
no women teachers will have resumed work
lost nothing female journalists they
have resumed their work well it's
nothing
um yeah sure they said the same thing
last time by the way
so um
sky news asked what the taliban would
say to the families of people who tried
to who of those who died trying to help
afghanistan quote they occupied our
country if we occupy your country what
would you say to me what if i killed
your people in your country what will
you say i think all people suffered a
lot bloodshed destruction everything we
say the past is the past part of our
past history now we want to focus on the
future yeah sure okay so the taliban are
in charge they're they're setting the
deadline and they've said there will be
consequences if we move past august 31st
which of course means that the united
states is now
basically taliban is playing the tune
and the united states the most powerful
country in the history of the world is
dancing to the tune of a bunch of 8th
century barbarians
armed with weapons that we gave them
so that's that's great
the way that we are coping with this
according to defense secretary lloyd
austin is we are now ordering commercial
airlines to provide passenger jets to
help with the growing us military
operation
lloyd austin activated stage one of the
civil reserve air fleet created in 1952
after the berlin airlift to provide 18
airliners to help ferry passengers
arriving at bases in the middle east
from afghanistan according to the
pentagon spokesperson the current
activation is for 18 planes four from
the united airlines three from american
atlas air delta airlines and omni air
and two from hawaiian airlines
captain john perkins spokesman for the
military's transportation command said
the commercial airliners would begin
service on monday or tuesday they would
fly evacuees from the middle east to
europe and from europe to the united
states
so obviously this is a well-planned
well-coordinated effort when you have to
call on hawaiian airlines to airlift
people out of afghanistan
not gonna say that's on their normal
flight schedule
it's like so yesterday they were flying
from you know lax to maui today
the us military is like okay we're gonna
need you to uh redirect to kabul
how'd you love to be on that flight crew
gang
captain perkins said in a telephone
interview the military had requested
wide-body long-haul aircrafts capable of
carrying several hundred passengers he
said the discussions had started with
the airlines last week and some carriers
had volunteered but the demand was great
enough for austin to order more airlines
to honor their obligations under the
reserve fleet program
civilian planes would not fly into or
out of kabul where rapidly deteriorating
security situation is hampered instead
they would help transport thousands of
afghans arriving in bahrain qatar and
the uae so they're not actually flying
into kabul but they are flying into the
middle east where they weren't flying
before and they'll be flying people out
of there that's how well coordinated
this effort has been
meanwhile isis is back so that's
exciting
local staff members of us embassy in
kabul are deeply disheartened by u.s
evacuation orders and have expressed a
deep sense of betrayal according to nbc
news by the way
there was a cable that said memos had
been sent to afghan staff at the embassy
on wednesday inviting them to head to
hamid karzai international airport in
kabul it told them to take food and
prepare for difficult conditions no one
anticipated the brutal experience that
occurred according to the embassy staff
staffers reported being jostled hit spat
on and cursed at by taliban fighters
near the airport adding criminals were
taking advantage of the chaos while the
us military tried to maintain order in
an extremely physical situation some
staff members reported they were almost
separated from their kids others
collapsed and crushed people and had to
be taken to the hospital with injuries
according to the cable others said they
had collapsed down the road because of
heat exhaustion
one staff member said we'd be better to
die under the taliban's bullet than face
the crowds again happy to die here but
dignity and pride said another
a third accused the u.s for prioritizing
the afghan government elite with
contacts in america over american
embassy staffers
so good times in just one second we'll
get to the isis reports because
apparently isis is back in country and
uh and doing what they do best so
everything is working out wonderfully
first let us talk about the fact that
you don't want to go to the auto parts
store because he wants to go to the auto
parts store and we live in a wonderful
country
and there are lots of services that are
available to you like the interwebs so
why would you stand in line in an auto
parts store you get to the front of the
line you get some doofus at the front
who tells you all about the different
parts they have and then says they are
out of stock for the part you need
orders it up charges you it says come
back in two weeks why not just go to the
internet and use rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts they're a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers the catalog is
unique remarkably easy to navigate you
can quickly see all the parts available
for your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer the
last thing anyone wants to do is spend
hours in an auto parts store it sounds
terrible go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right shapiro in there how did
you hear about usbox so they know that
we sent you again that's rockauto.com go
check them out right now and write
shapiro in there how did you hear about
usbox so they know that we sent you
meanwhile in case you were wondering
whether the um
the terror problem in afghanistan is uh
going to continue to be a problem the
answer is isis is back so that's
exciting stuff according to the wall
street journal the u.s warned the
islamic state poses a threat to
americans in afghanistan as the biden
administration seeks to evacuate
thousands of u.s citizens and afghan
allies the threat is real it is acute it
is persistent it is something we are
focused on with every tool in our
arsenal said jake sullivan the
president's national security advisor he
told cnn on sunday when asked whether
crowds at kabul international airport
are vulnerable to terrorist attacks
because
by the way that is a real possibility
you got a bunch of americans and afghan
allies who are just lined up around this
place
all it would take is one isis guy with
an ak to mow down a bunch of those
people president biden speaking from the
white house said quote we know that
terrorists may seek to exploit the
situation and target innocent afghans or
american troops or maintaining constant
vigilance to monitor and disrupt threats
from any source
concerns over islamic state attacks were
one reason the u.s embassy warned
americans on saturday to avoid traveling
to the airport in kabul and to avoid
airport gates defense officials have
said so a question if americans can't go
to the airport and they can't go to the
airport gates and you're worried about
isis killing them what are you going to
do now
what exactly is your plan guys islamic
state is among several terrorist groups
present in afghanistan each with a
different relationship with the taliban
the taliban had harbored al-qaeda before
the group's terrorist attacks on the us
in 2001 reports have surfaced the
taliban have freed al-qaeda fighters
from prisons as they gained control of
the country this month
isis and the taliban have sometimes
fought over control of the territory in
afghanistan the taliban after taking
over kabul executed the former head of
isis in south asia who had been in a
government prison
assisting the u.s evacuation effort
roughly two dozen countries have agreed
to take in afghan evacuees while they
are processed the bite administration
has also ordered commercial airliners to
help evacuate
mr sullivan was one of several u.s
national security officials to appear on
sunday morning news programs to discuss
the evacuation effort but honestly if
you think things are bad now over there
wait until there's an actual terrorist
attack on the gates outside of the kabul
airport
because then you're just relying on the
taliban to basically provide
full-fledged security
right now it's not just will the taliban
be nice enough to allow our people to
leave if we bribe them now the question
is will the taliban actually go to war
with al-qaeda to stop al-qaeda from
killing people who are outside the gates
and that is a very real possibility
given the fact that state department is
now telling people not to go to the
airport because they're afraid of
terrorist attacks
un officials have reported al-qaeda
operations are still present in some
areas u.s intelligence assessments have
said the group could completely
reconstitute in afghanistan within 18
months to two years after an afghan
after an american withdrawal u.s
officials have since said they are
likely to reassess that timeline to like
15 minutes
and what a full-scale disaster so the
good news is we have a president who is
clearly with us a president who is
clearly in control a president who has
defined this policy and planned for
every contingency and totally knows
what's going on right now
or alternatively we have a house plant
who is not with us and has not been with
us for quite some time
so chris wallace had on the secretary of
state tony blanken who has really
outdone himself this time and tony
blinken is not good at his job and he is
extraordinarily not good at his job
chris wallace on fox news he asked him
you know the president keeps saying
things that are not true like over and
over the president said al qaeda isn't
in afghanistan that's not true the
president has said that there is no
violence outside the airport gates that
it's not true the president has
suggested that the afghan security
forces didn't fight at all we're not
capable of fighting that's not true like
he said a lot of things that are not
true is he with us like is the president
like on this planet
as of anytime recently or is he just too
wrapped up in that matlock marathon
on the on cable channel 799 to pay
attention to what's like what's going on
here's chris wallace with tony blinken
tony blinken's answer here is a somewhat
disturbing
mr secretary does the president not know
what's going on
this is an incredibly
emotional time
for for many of us uh and including
allies and partners who've been shoulder
to shoulder with us in afghanistan for
20 years so the question was does the
president know what's going on
and the secretary of state's answer is
it's an emotional time for us all
do you feel quieted do you feel that
things are going well do you feel that
this president is in charge
um
that's not the answer you're looking for
the answer you're looking for is the
president knows every single thing
that's going on right at this moment we
are making decisions in real time we
plan for every contingency sometimes
those plans go wrong and we are making
contingencies for the contingencies but
the president is up to date and apprised
instead we get it's an emotional time
i mean
let's be let's be real the emotions are
running high right now
uh
yeah
great also who's in control secretary of
state tony blanken who's in control
here's tony blinken explaining the
taliban are in control now you should be
asking yourself the question why
you should be asking why and the answer
of course is because joe biden decided
to put them in control period end of
story that is the only reason the
taliban are in control
someone in our audience might listen to
you mr secretary and say oh so we have
to ask the taliban for permission for
american citizens to leave true or not
true
they they are in control of kabul
that is the reality uh that's the
reality uh that uh that we have to deal
with how comfortable are you with that
mr secretary
um
my what i'm what i'm uh focused on uh
what we're all focused on
is getting people out and making sure
that we're doing everything possible to
do that and in this case uh it uh is i
think a requirement of the job uh to be
in contact with uh with the taliban
which controls kabul um
if your draw's not on the floor after
listening to clips like that i don't
know what to tell you the most powerful
country in world history
has put the taliban in charge of kabul
with thousands of american citizens
still stranded in country
the taliban is in charge of the gate in
terms of who gets in who gets out the
taliban is supposed to be in charge of
preventing terror attacks on americans
and afghans people who they want to kill
by the way and tony blinkens like
well you know they're in charge and when
asked whether he is comfortable with
that his answer is we're focused on the
future
that's good well the good news is that
at least if biden isn't with it then
tony blinken is right i mean tony
blinken obviously is on top of this
thing here is tony blanken talking about
the people in afghanistan that he's been
in touch with
what we've seen uh majors is uh
is also pretty remarkable
go back a week the government fell uh
and by the way i was on the phone with
with president karzai the day before
when he was telling me his intent as he
put it to fight to the death well the
next day he was gone the military
collapsed
um
he was on the phone well last week he
was on the phone with president karzai
that's weird
the reason it's weird is because coming
karzai has not been president of
afghanistan since 2014.
it's now 2021.
so he meant
presumably muhammad ashraf ghani right
he's the guy who fled
[Music]
but it's disquieting the secretary of
state doesn't know who the hell he was
talking to nor does he care let's be
real about this they don't care what's
going on here they don't care i mean
chuck schumer is is dancing
at like events with stephen colbert and
nancy pelosi is off doing wine and dines
in napa without masks
and the president is busy drinking
insure
and taking naps at 11 o'clock in the
morning like no one there is no hand at
this wheel there is no hand at the
tiller
and because there's no hand at the wheel
no hand at the tiller a decision to to
direct
the to to essentially tie the tiller
such that the ship is directed
directly at an iceberg and then to be
like well i guess you know if an
emergency arises we'll do something
the emergency is here you guys are
incompetent
you hadn't it's
it's
jaw-dropping it's all jaw-dropping
okay and if you were worried that it was
just maybe it's just biden staffers not
biden himself
so um there is only one problem with
this which is that biden is the one who
made this call and there was a tweet
from axios yesterday saying joe biden
doesn't plan to fire anyone over this
well who the hell would he fire himself
this is his policy beginning to end
this was his policy there are two major
decisions that have been made
in the in the recent history of
afghanistan
aside from the 2014 drawdown by barack
obama
two major events right two major events
i think is fairer to say one is the
killing of osama bin laden the other is
the pull out joe biden was on the wrong
side of both of those joe biden opposed
the raid that killed bin laden
and now
he was in favor of withdrawing with no
contingency plan radically
without without any sort of of advance
for like
you would know how to do this you like
the regular regular joe plumber joe you
would know how to do this
right let's say that a flood was about
to hit your house
a flood was about to hit your house
and you have a couple of choices one is
you could leave your children and all of
your belongings in your house and you
could just flee and then when the flood
hits you could try to row back in on a
rowboat to get those things or knowing
the flood is coming you could
theoretically take your kids put them in
the back of the car take the boxes of
stuff you want put that in the back of
the car and then drive away and call the
insurance company
which one do you think joe biden did
here joe biden was like not only is the
flood coming i'm going to unleash the
flood i'm going to blow up the dam right
the levee's going to break i'm going to
be responsible for that the flood is
coming also i'm going to leave my kids
in the house over here and all of my
pictures all my other photos i'm just
going to leave that stuff there
and hey
that was an unforeseen but i had a plan
for it my plan is that i was going to
come back later in a row boat
that's the
okay so if you just think that's his
team that came up with that plan
first of all we have multiple reports of
people telling joe biden this was the
dumbest plan ever this is a terrible
terrible stupid thing to do and joe
biden ignoring them because he is a dumb
band he's always been kind of a dumb man
according to barack obama right never
underestimate joe's capacity to f things
up quote barack obama
who's his vice president okay but
now we have joe biden who is not at the
top of his game and there was never a
top of his game
we're not talking about like michael
jordan in the declining washington
wizards years we're talking about benoit
benjamin at the end of his career okay
this is not somebody who is like a great
guy a great player who has now declined
somewhat from his peak
we're talking about like the fringe guy
or something like brian scalibrini at
the end of the bench
and it's the waning days of his career
when he can no longer move
and by the way no rep on brunoise
benjamin or brian scalabrine both of
whom were much better at their jobs than
joe biden is at his job which is saying
a lot because neither one of them were
grand players like this is
this is unbelievable it's incredible
okay so here is joe biden being even
less competent than usual over the
weekend
he he got he always gets very testy if
you ask him like a tough question about
the fact that he just you know blew up
america's foreign policy like completely
blew it up because china is is ecstatic
today
right we just lost every base we have in
the region it's not just that we've lost
bases in afghanistan lost our bases in
in pakistan
we have no surrounding bases our nearest
space is now in qatar
okay which is hundreds of miles away
we have no over the horizon capacity we
lost all of our intelligence sources on
the ground who are likely to be murdered
by the taliban
china is ecstatic because now they have
land access
they now have a basically a bridge all
the way from china through afghanistan
into iran
to syria to to lebanon like this is all
chinese allied territory now you got the
russians who are doing the same thing
and it's it's a full-scale geopolitical
disaster and if you're an american ally
you're looking at the biden
administration going i don't trust you
i'm gonna have to triangulate now i'm
gonna have to look to russia and china
try to cut a few deals try to shore up
you know kind of
backfill some sort of national security
here
it's i've never seen anything remotely
like it and the president of the united
states is not with us there's nothing
going on upstairs the lights are on but
nobody is home and frankly the lights
are dimming very very quickly
here's the president of the united
states getting to test you and ask
questions about it
i don't trust anybody including you i
love you but you know there's not a lot
of people i trust okay he was asked if
he trusts the taliban now and the reason
he's asked that is because he is
trusting the taliban to allow americans
out
and the reporter says do you trust him
he said i don't trust you man i don't
trust anybody trust no one well i wish
you'd abided by that rule before you
pulled all american soldiers out of
kabul preventing us from getting our
people out
if you didn't trust them why did you do
this this was unnecessary this wasn't
the taliban defeated the united states
military in armed combat this was not
even the unit the taliban defeated the
afghan military in armed combat this was
the united states withdrew close air
support from the afghan military
withdrew all american military
contractors allowing the afghan air
force to fly this is the united states
completely destroyed the basis for the
afghan army and the afghan army
disappeared
the taliban didn't take kabul in ground
assault fighting they didn't take kabul
in hand-to-hand combat they took kabul
without firing a shot they took kandahar
without firing a shot they took missouri
sharif without firing a shot that's
because of biden no one else just biden
that's all
it's unreal
now what's hilarious is that he says
like these two clips back to back so he
says i don't trust anybody including you
i don't trust the taliban but he's going
to urge the taliban to respect the
well-beings of afghans oh i'm sure
that's what's going to happen mr
president i'm sure that's what's going
to happen now you've pulled out all
protective forces and destroyed all of
our allies and left anyone who allied
with us at the risk of being shot in the
face by the taliban
i am sure that the taliban are thinking
to themselves how can we protect the
well-being of afghans in coordination
with the desires of the biden
administration that just gave us apache
attack helicopters
the what
what the what in the actual
there's no way to do the show without
the f word there's just no way
here is here's the president of the
united states
the taliban has a
taliban has to make a fundamental
decision
is a taliban going to attempt to
be able to unite and provide for
the well-being of the people of
afghanistan which no one group has ever
done
since before
feeling for hundreds of years
and if it does it's going to need
everything from additional help in terms
of economic assistance trade and a whole
range of things the taliban is going to
have
the taliban is going to have to make a
decision okay so let's say they have to
make a decision who knows what decision
they're going to make on the one hand
they could do all the things joe biden
wants them to do
on the other hand they could tell him to
go screw himself
kill everyone who allied with us stuff
the women back into burqas and then back
into the basement and then rape them
and do whatever the hell they want i
wonder which one i have
my hands up here i i think i know the
answer i think
it's a hard question i think i know the
answer to this one that's what the
taliban is going to do
i think i know this is really rough by
the way joe biden was then asked a
question about isis which again is
rising in afghanistan and here was joe
biden's electrifying response
in case you can't see that that's the
president of the united states walking
and doddering out the back door i kid
you not
it's the president of the united states
turning around and walking out the back
door
yeah man this is gonna go
fantastically well the good news is that
if joe biden should uh should actually
be declared incompetent which may in
fact have to happen at some point here
uh then uh the person who replaced him
kamala hair she's up for the job right
oh wait we have we have video of kamala
harris too
what an administration this is
but no bad tweets no bad tweets
is that a moment first
the men shapiro show is proud to be
supported by grand canyon university an
affordable christian university one of
the largest fastest growing universities
in the country which means on the planet
located in sunny phoenix arizona gcu is
ranked top 20 for best college campuses
in america offers over 275 engaging
academic programs with over 240 online i
visited grand canyon university a couple
of years ago the student body is just
spectacular it is a wonderful wonderful
place gcu integrates the free market
system with a welcoming christian
worldview perspective into its academic
programs so you can put your faith into
action and help transform communities
their university that actually has
values as shown by the fact that they
sponsor shows like this one in 2020 gcu
students received over 290 million bucks
in scholarships with many attending gcu
for less than the cost of a state
university find your purpose at gcu
private christian affordable now i'm
constantly ranting on this show about
how the university system has completely
collapsed and is churning out woke
garbage by the by the ton by the metric
ton not so at gcu where values still
matter visit gcu.edu slash my offer see
what scholarships you qualify for it's
gonna be worth your time okay we'll get
to more in a second including kamala
harris tackling her way through life
first the best way to keep up with the
world that never stops spinning is to
read about it the daily wires reader
pass has you covered for just four bucks
a month the daily wire readers pass
unlocks exclusive editorial content that
unpacks trending political and cultural
topics penned by everyone from me to
candace owens to dan crenshaw plus you
can catch our in-depth analysis pieces
that offer a point of view you won't get
anywhere else or take a deep dive with
readers past collections different
series of articles on a given subject
current collections include the hunter
biden files and blm the organization
behind movement
when you sign up with readers pass you
also get access to the morning wire
newsletter a monday through saturday
email covering the top stories you need
to know available only to daily wire
members all this can be yours for just
four bucks a month so act fast right now
we are offering a one month free trial
it's a good deal it's also never been a
better time to take it so what exactly
are you waiting for get informed to get
a reader's pass today you are listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
well you might be asking yourself
whether joe biden is competent and the
answer of course
is not he is not i mean joe biden is
literally just forgetting things now
he in this same presser he literally
forgot the name of his fema
administrator
which
i understand is a forgettable thing but
not if you're president and it's your
administrator i know the names of my
producers takes me a little while but
once i know him i know him here's the
president of the united states just
forget by the way he's there's a
teleprompter in front of him he's
speaking from teleprompter at this point
i can't
think of anyone better to lead this
operation than
than uh
deanne
criswell of
fema um she's she before she headed up
fema she led the emergency response in
new york city i can't think of anyone
better to lead this effort than shabbat
exam yes boosie game judean
yeah man okay well the good news is
waiting in the wings we have kamala
harris the most competent person she is
so competent so competent she's deeply
ready for this job she's so ready for
this job she'll be ready day one
i mean she might not need to be ready
day one but like we're or maybe what 150
days into this administration so by day
200 she might need to be ready here is
kamala harris cackling like a crazy
person uh when when uh asked about
afghanistan which is always heartening
it's always great when the vice
president of the united states who by
the way
i don't know who books her travel
schedule you know she's headed to
vietnam today
like she's flying to vietnam
optics gang optics
what's your response
of americans hold on
hold on everybody
um i want to talk about two things first
afghanistan
we couldn't have a higher priority right
now and in particular our priority is
making sure that we safely evacuate
american citizens man is that a weird
tick is that a weird tick or what
madam vice president what about
afghanistan well let's let's take a
break here for that
what is that uh but the good news is
she's not the only one laughing i've got
a lot of people laughing these days joe
biden is laughing it up so there's a
brand new poll
and shows that americans think he's
doing an unbelievably crappy job on
afghanistan the new poll which is uh
from
nbc news or cbs news rather cbs news you
gov
according to americans there's a poll
from three days ago
removal of u.s troops from afghanistan
has gone very badly 44
somewhat badly 30 percent somewhat well
very well five percent so the five
percent is ron clayne in the taliban
meanwhile 74 of americans think this is
either gone very badly or somewhat badly
and the 21 who say somewhat well are
actually in the pay of the democratic
party presumably so joe biden was asked
about this it is hilarious to joe biden
the new poll out today shows americans
wanted to withdraw from afghanistan
but they disapprove of the way you've
handled it paul also found that based in
part and what's transpired in the last
week a majority of americans
and forgive me i'm just the messenger no
longer consider you to be competent
focused or effective in the job i
haven't seen that poll
it's out there um from cbs this morning
um what would you say
[Laughter]
so remember that time that donald trump
would just deny polls remember there
would be people who'd read him poll
numbers he'd just be like fake news fake
paw not real and everybody in the middle
go how dare he it's a real poll but he's
just not going to believe polls now
see read joe biden a poll saying that
most americans think that he's not
competent and john's like ah
and then he breaks out the caesar romero
honestly i've never seen a vice
president and a president who both
resembled the joke or bizarrely it's
it's a it's a weird it's a weird thing
it's very very odd
but it's all fine probably it's all fine
he's uh he everything is solid
it's going well
we're being told by this administration
that that the competence is um is at
record high levels they are laser
focused on what they need to do here
oh boy
alrighty we'll be back here a little
later today with an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out the
michael mills show today he discusses
the spike in transit surgeries you can
hear more details about that story over
on michael's show that's available right
now i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
the secretary of state refuses to
confirm that joe biden knows what's
going on the taliban trolls the west on
twitter and australia kills puppies to
fight kovid check it out on the michael
knowles show
[Music]